oksana tiene 31 años y es madre de saya
un niño de 6 años que tiene una
disfunción renal y necesita hemodiálisis
llegó aquí hace cuatro meses y su hijo
no puede abandonar el hospital
si nos fuimos de la biacs no porque
fuera peligroso sino para curar a mi
hijo
oksana explica que no tuvo otra opción
mi familia está preocupada por mí por mi
hijo pero yo no puedo volver a la vida
ahora me tengo que quedar aquí en kiev
es uno de los 200 pacientes ingresados
en este centro hospitalario e izquierda
que opera bajo las bombas y es el más
importante del país un hospital que ha
tenido que armar búnkeres improvisados
para mantener a salvo a sus pequeños
pacientes tenemos algunos lugares
seguros donde los protegemos de las
bombas en los subterráneos y no es bueno
para los niños con problemas oncológicos
porque no hay buena ventilación hay
muchísimas personas hay poca agua y poca
libertad de movimiento y por tanto hay
riesgo de infecciones el médico subraya
que el problema número uno en la guerra
ah
la causa de la guerra no podemos dar una
atención médica adecuada a los niños en
todas partes hay disparos problemas
distintos tipos de problemas tenemos a
cuatro niños que han llegado heridos un
niño murió antes de llegar a nuestro
hospital y otro sufrió una muerte
clínica poco después de ser ingresado
rumbo
pero no solo los niños sufren
todos los niños al igual que los padres
están en una situación muy difícil
porque la guerra es un gran estrés para
ellos nos faltan medicinas no nos llegan
y el problema no es sólo de los niños
sino también de los padres que necesitan
tranquilizantes para afrontar estos días
la mayor sorpresa fue la de encontrarse
ante un conflicto que nos esperaban
la guerra fue inesperada a nosotros
mismos no podemos entender cómo pudo
ocurrir
un drama que no afecta sólo a los niños
del hospital o inmediato según un set en
ucrania las hostilidades son una amenaza
inmediata para 76 millones de niños